E
KENNEDY MICHELLE SOPHIA.
WE ARE AWAITING A RULING ON THE
FATE OF TITLE 42 WITH REPORTS IT
COULD COME AS EARLY AS TODAY.
NOW THAT THE TRUMP ARROW BORDER
RESTRICTIONS ARE SAID TO EXPIRE
ON MONDAY ILLEGAL MIGRANT
ENCOUNTERS, WHICH ARTIE SHOT HER
STOMACH SHATTERED RECORDS MONTH
AFTER MONTH ARE ALREADY
EXPLAINING THAT SOME AREAS
SEEING 1800 APPREHENSIONS IN
JUST 24 HOURS.
WITH TITLE 42 EXPECTED TO END,
BORDER COUNTIES ARE NOW BRACING
FOR A DISASTER.
EL PASO PREPARING TO DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY AS THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS WARNS
6 MILLION MIGRANTS TO COME IN
EACH YEAR.
THAT IS ROUGHLY EQUAL TO THE
POPULATION OF HOUSTON EVERY 12
MONTHS.
AND WITH ALL OF US HANGING IN
THE BALANCE, YOU MAY BE
WONDERING WHAT OUR BORDERS ARE
UP TO TODAY.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS IS
TALKING ABOUT CLEAN SCHOOL
BUSES.
KAYLEE, AS ALWAYS, THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS M.I.A. ON THIS
BORDER CRISIS.
BUT TODAY, SHE IS EXPECTED TO
ANNOUNCE CERTAIN REGULATIONS AND
EXPECTATIONS SURROUNDING A LOW
EMISSION SCHOOL BUSES.
WHAT APPS TIMING AND WHAT GREAT
PRIORITIES WHEN YOU SAY?
>> Kalie: RIGHT I'M STILL NOT
LISTENING TO THE POSTERS COME
EMILY COME WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
JOE BIDEN'S POSTERS KIM AND HIM
AND SAID HEY I KNOW IT MAY
FAIRLY GUARD ADMINISTRATION'S
GOING GREAT BUT THERE'S THIS
THING ON THE HORIZON CALLED
IMMIGRATION AND THE BORDER ON
FIRE MAY BE SHOULD PAY ATTENTION
TO IT AND HE DIDN'T.
NEITHER HAS KAMALA HARRIS.
FOX NEWS DIGITAL IT DID SOME
REALLY GOOD REPORTING ON THIS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY FOUND.
IN JUNE, SHE VISITS THE BORDER
FOR FOLLOW-UP, OKAY?
IN AUGUST JUST TO LIMITED PRESS
EVENTS.
THERE BEEN NO SUCH PRESS EVENTS
SINCE LAST JUNE.
AND SINCE JUNE THE OTHER
RECORDED ACTIVITY WE HAVE FROM
AROUND THE BORDER IS JANUARY SHE
WENT TO HONDURAS, APRIL SHOWED A
PHONE CALL, MAY SHE HAD A
MEETING, GOOD JOB,
KAMALA HARRIS.
A MEETING COME UP PHONE CALL, A
PHOTO OP OF THE BORDER, PHOTO OP
IN HONDURAS, AND NOW YOU HAVE
TITLE 42 ABOUT TO EXPIRE MEANING
2 MILLION MORE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
WOULD HAVE CROSSED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION THE ONLY
CONCLUSION YOU ARE LEFT WITH,
EMILY, IS THAT THEY ARE
INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO MAKE
THIS WORSE.
BECAUSE WHY WOULD YOU NOT LISTS
A MASK MANDATE ON THE AIRLINES
UNTIL JUDGE FORCES U.S. CITIZENS
BUT WHAT YOU WILL WILLINGLY DOOM
ILLEGAL MINERS BEFORE AND THAT
MAKES NO SENSE.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT AND AS
THE TERRIFIC COMMUNICATIONS WITH
THE LACK OF SUPPORT THERE FOR
ALL OF THOSE BORDER STATES.
FRANKLY COME ALL THE REST OF THE
24 STATES THAT HAVE JOINED THIS
LAWSUIT TRYING TO KEEP TITLE 42
IN PLACE.
IN FACT, GOVERNOR ABBOTT OF
TEXAS SAID LAST TIME YOU HAVE TO
GOVERN DOMINIC PRESIDENT BIDEN
WAS 2021.
WHAT IS A TELL YOU, MICHELLE?
SPEAK I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THEM.
IT'S DEVASTATING TO THOSE BORDER
STATES BUT IT'S REALLY
DEVASTATING TO THE COUNTRY.
LOOK, ALL WE WANT IS AN ORDERLY
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BY RIPPING OFF THIS TITLE 42
BAND-AID YOU ARE STILL LEADING
I'LL MAKE LEAVING THE PATIENT TO
BLEEDING, LEAVING THE PATIENT
REALLY NEEDING SOME SURGERY.
WE HEAR AGAIN AND AGAIN FROM
NANCY PELOSI AND OTHERS WE NEED
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
I'VE BEEN HEARING THAT SINCE I
WAS ALIVE, SINCE I'VE BEEN
ALIVE.
THAT IS GOING TO TAKE SO LONG TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THERE IS GOING TO BE SO MUCH
DISAGREEMENT IN ALL OF THE
DETAILS.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE.
WE NEED TO LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
THE BORDER FIRST.
AND THEN TAKE CARE OF THE REST
OF THE IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THIS IS A MAJOR PROBLEM.
WE ARE HAVING FENTANYL GET
THROUGH WITH THE CARTELS
CONTROLLING SO MUCH OF WHAT IS
GOING ON OVER THERE.
IT REALLY DOES LOOK LIKE THIS
ADMINISTRATION JUST DOESN'T CARE
OR SEE AN ADVANTAGE HERE AND
THAT IS HARD FOR MOST AMERICANS
TO TAKE.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT, AND
KENNEDY, IN TERMS OF THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS OVER TITLE 42
THE ADMINISTERING OF THEM ARE
ACKNOWLEDGED ALL OF THE
ARGUMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATES WHERE THEY SAY LOOK, OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM EDUCATION,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, PROCESSING WILL
ABSOLUTELY CRUSH NOT ONLY OUR
LOCAL POPULATIONS, THEY SAY, BUT
ALSO THE MIGRANTS WHO DESERVE AS
WELL TO BE PROCESSED IN AN
ORDERLY FASHION TO MICHELLE'S
POINT ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION
REFORM NEEDED.
INSTEAD, THE GOVERNMENT SIMPLY
SAID THE CDC IS THE ONE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE AUTHORITY,
AND THEREFORE THAT'S WHY SHOULD
BE LIFTED.
ALL THOSE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
AND MIGRANTS LIVE WHO WILL BE
AFFECTED NEGATIVELY.
>> IT DOES NOT AFFECT THOSE WHO
MAY BE DEMOCRAT VOTERS EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT AND WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT NOW.
THEY HAVE HAD A YEAR.
LAST YEAR WITH THESE RECORD
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE COMING OVER
THE BORDER AND RIGHT NOW WITH
TITLE 42 GOING AWAY, WHATEVER
GREAT MARKETING THE CARTELS HAD
LAST YEAR IS EVEN BETTER THIS
YEAR BECAUSE THEY ARE LIKE THEY
ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO SEND YOU
BACK TO MEXICO WHEN YOU SEEKING
ASYLUM.
YOU ARE IN.
THEY HAVE HAD A YEAR TO HAVE A
CONFERENCE OF APPROACH, EVEN IF
THE COMPREHENSION ISN'T IN
LEGISLATION.
THEY COULD HAVE HAD MORE JUDGES,
MORE PROCESSING FACILITIES, MORE
INSIGHT.
AND OH, HARRIS WHERE WEARS
PANTSUITS.
I KNOW PANTSUITS HAVE SLEEVES.
SHE SHOULD BE ROLLING THEM UP
AND DOING THE REALLY HARD WORK
THAT IS REQUIRED TO SOLVE THIS.
BECAUSE AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING, PEOPLE TRYING TO GET
INTO THE COUNTRY OF SUFFERING
AND DYING.
IF SHE IS THE CZARINA SHE MUST
RULE ON THIS ONE.
>> Emily: JIMMY THIS IS SUCH
AN EXPONENTIAL ASSESS, RIGHT?
ONE DAY WITH AN OPEN SPIGOT HAS
A RIPPLE EFFECT AND IMPACT THAT
IS FAR GREATER THAN THE ACTUAL
NUMERIC EQUIVALENT OF THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE.
BASICALLY IT'S REALLY HARD TO
SET STUFF THIS GENIE BACK IN THE
BOTTLE EVERY DAY GOES BY.
>> Jimmy: THE BORDER CRISIS IS
REALLY EMBLEMATIC OF WHY